[Music]
you know one of the most recognizable
landmarks near Dallas is of course AT&T
Stadium
it's home to the Dallas Cowboys and
starting this weekend it will be hosting
the NCAA Final Four so all this week to
honor the Final Four taking place here
in Texas we're doing what anyone would
do
we're shooting full court baskets
outside AT&T Stadium with a help of a
catapult we stole from Mark Cuban's
bedroom now this is a full court
three-point shot and only that instead
of shooting a basketball anyone can do
that
each night we're launching something
uniquely Texan this week so far we've
launched a 72-ounce steak from the Big
Texan a baby born at Baylor Medical
Center Willie Nelson's back-taxes a
pinata filled with beef brisket and
armadillo roadkill well tonight we'll be
shooting the very first Texas
Instruments handheld calculator
the calculator was made in 1972 it
weighs over 48 pounds there it is ladies
and gentlemen for three that just wasn't
even close
but this is Texas we don't give up
reload the calculator
[Applause]
incredible
incredible marksmanship for our final
object of the week we're launching a
huge enemy to all the people of Dallas a
Washington [ __ ] fan but she knows
something we're in Dallas a basketball
net is too good for a [ __ ] fan so
we're going to bring out a dumpster
ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
you can also watch all those catapult
shots in 360 degree video right on your
computer tablet or phone thanks to our
revolutionary conan 360 camera brought
to you by AT&T it's pretty cool
there's the conan 360 replay plan out
and you can watch the shots from any
angle using this breakthrough technology
pretty cool there's a guy just chilling
in the corner we'll take a break